[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby and i will be your driver on this
journey
i'm excited because today we have some
really interesting games to talk about
magnus carlsen of course is on his road
to 2900
so rather than the road to 2000 tonight
we're going to try to put ourselves to
magnus's shoes see what he's doing to
try to achieve this this all-time high
rating that he has assigned himself as
his next goal in chess
world championships just not satisfying
enough anymore for him he's got to break
2 900.
so to do that he is playing in the tata
steel uh chess tournament going on right
now
uh and he's having a pretty good
tournament he has six and a half out of
nine he's leading in first place at the
time of this video
um and he's playing so well that he's
even gaining two whole rating points
that's how tough it is for him at the
rating he's at right now even leading
the tournament with plus four i think is
not enough to gain any substantial
rating plus two is all he gets
uh but he's playing some really exciting
chess not since vladimir kramnik have i
seen someone win so many games in the
catalan so those are the games i want to
focus on today because he's had some
really exciting stuff uh some
interesting new ideas that he's bringing
to the catalan and he's just crushing
everybody in this opening so
to start with i want to take a look at
his most recent win i believe which is
against uh shock mohammed yarov so last
week we featured shock with his amazing
move 3g4 this week he's on the other
side of things with the black pieces so
to start magnus does play the catalan
which of course starts d4 knight f6 um
magnus chose knight f3 here
d5 c4 e6 and g3 the the key move
denoting the catalan
now there are a number of ways black
wants to respond to this uh these days
the move bishop b4 is quite popular this
should be seven also one of the main
lines um
just to make sure i'm not missing
anything you can even do c6 or c5
although i'm a little suspicious of
these moves
and last but not least this move d takes
c4 is very popular rather than develop
the dark square bishop first black just
immediately captures this pawn on c4
and waits to do something with this
bishop on the next turn or even further
after
magnus continues with bishop g2 normal
catalan plans
and then black here decides to do the
immediate bishop b for check this is
definitely not forced by any means but
this is what a shock decides to go for
here so why play bishop b4
uh well the idea is that white is not
going to have the most comfortable
response to this move if you play knight
c3 your knight's kind of pinned uh kind
of pinned and you're removing yourself
of any opportunities to potentially
capture this pawn on c4 with the knight
if you play knight d2 then this bishop
is hard to develop and last but not
least bishop d2 is the main move which
is what magnus magnus chooses in the
game but now shock has this nice idea to
play a5 sort of plant this bishop here
on the b4 square and rather annoyingly
kind of just leave it there in magnus's
face and make things difficult for white
namely this bishop interferes with
white's access to the d4 pawn which is
going to be relevant in some variations
we see coming up magnus castles one of
the main moves black castles in response
and now magnus finds a really
interesting way to solve his opening
problems the move he chooses
has been played before but it definitely
is a bit of a sideline uh that being
said i think it makes a lot of sense and
it led to a pretty nice position for him
here so
let's take a moment to pause and just
sort of figure out
what is happening in this opening what
is white trying to do what is black
trying to do and uh and how are we gonna
go about doing it so
what is one of white's main priorities
here as it always is in the catalan the
the main priority right from the opening
what are you trying to do to
secure an advantage
asking you asking the chat live audience
online audience anybody
and you can take a moment to think if
you want control
yep so controlling this diagonal is the
main thing
but of course for the moment black is up
a pawn and so first and foremost white's
priority is uh either making sure we get
this pawn back or making sure that we're
getting enough compensation for it so
how would we go about trying to to
recapture our pawn
there's a few common ideas
i thought it was exchange on b4 and then
uh knight a2 to put pressure on the
input
yep and attacking the c4 pawn
and you have to be careful with uh b5 is
what you're saying because
you move this knight
somewhere
um and let's say 95 and are attacking
this rook on a8 so those are that's a
lot of the common motifs here uh you
definitely hit a lot of them the thing i
would be wary of is this move bishop
takes b4 this is sort of exactly what
black is hoping for because
this rook on a8 often finds itself in an
uncomfortable uncomfortable position as
you were saying
uh but if we are able to open this a
file
this is going to give white some pretty
serious problems
down this file
and for example after knight b to d2
you're saying you do have to be careful
about this move because it discovered
attacks but the fact of the matter is uh
black might might not actually care all
that much you might just play b5 allow
something like this um either move this
rook or potentially even take on d4 and
we could get some exciting stuff for
black you know black is already up one
pawn and he might not mind sacrificing
this exchange
in order to keep this big pawn mass he's
got two pawns for it and some pretty
easy play rook d8 white's gonna have to
spend time extracting this bishop and
i'm not so sure i'm in love with this
variation for uh for white
alternatively of course something like
rook a6 is also totally playable here
and black is maintaining this pawn so
this is sort of the problem that that
white is faced with uh we want to
recapture this pawn but ideas of moving
this bishop and playing knight b to d2
are a little bit slow it might allow b5
um
and ideas of 95 are going to be really
difficult because this pawn is always
hanging and these are sort of difficult
problems for white so there's one more
really
natural move that white can play to try
to recapture this pawn and that move of
course as some people in the chat are
saying uh is the move queen to c2 this
is very very normal for the catalan you
come either queen a4 or queen c2 in this
case queen a4 doesn't make as much sense
because this bishop is sort of annoying
here on this square so bishop d7 for
example would push the queen back
uh but queen c2 seems to make a lot of
sense
uh however
this still is not going to be the the
most comfortable for white because black
now might uh consider capturing on d2
after we take back again this move b5 is
going to come
and again white would love to play this
move knight to e5 but it's just kind of
difficult to to play this move while
this e5 pawn is hanging you always have
to be worried about this
sorry d4 pawn
and black is going to have this pressure
so the idea that magnus comes up with to
improve his position is this strange
looking move e3
looks like you're
locking this bishop in on the d2 square
but this move does give you a lot of
solidity on d4 and that's really going
to free you up to play something like
knight e5 pressure this pawn on c4 open
up this bishop on the long diagonal
and improve your position
and e3 seems really really slow
but the sort of trick here is that it's
not so easy for black to play a useful
move without giving something up
for example it would make a lot of sense
to play this move b5 but e3 is already
aimed against this idea because now
again knight e5 is coming in very
quickly and this knight is going to be
very well placed here or even a4 first
something like knight c6 or something
like pawn to c6 and again knight to e5
and we're threatening this we've got
these ideas
uh and and white is definitely on on the
offensive i mean the play is going to
continue here like her k6
b3 for example but
uh white's having a lot of fun and this
e3 pawn is absolutely crucial to this
plan working
uh so magnus plays e3 sort of daring
black to go for this b5 type of stuff uh
against which he's now well prepared
with the knight e5 idea
um so shock also has to get creative he
anticipates that white is playing knight
e5 opening up this diagonal and he comes
up with the move rook to a6 which i
think is a pretty decent move
uh white now does continue with queen to
c2
again he's not as worried about these
ideas because he is ready to jump in
with 95 once again
and shock chooses b5
which makes sense he's solidifying the
position he got the rook off of this
diagonal playing useful moves uh so of
course what's the natural response to b5
i already kind of showed it in in one of
the lines here
yeah a4 or b3 both of these moves are
going to be really useful so a4 is how
magnus starts
c6 is very natural trying to just
preserve the uh punching
and magnus now plays knight to c3 sort
of shutting the door
on this bishop takes a d2 trait so
rather than pressuring c4 magnus is now
trying to pressure the b5 pawn which
which makes a lot of sense this is the
new weakness
in in the camp
and it's really interesting that
uh
shock decided not to take off this dark
squared bishop uh looking at a few
different of a few of the different
lines it does make sense to take this
piece because white does a lot of the
time want this knight on c3 rather than
d2 we definitely don't want to spend
time playing queen c2 queen takes d2 but
from what i've seen in this tournament
these strong players really hate taking
off this dark square bishop
because it's pretty clear that it's one
of white's worst pieces it's stuck
behind the pawn chain uh it can be
difficult to find a good square for it
and it's even sort of inhibiting play
down the d file
but
shock decides not to take it for all
those reasons which does allow this
knight to come out now to a good square
on c3
shock's next move is rook b6 defending
against the threat to the b pawn
and now we do see this move e4 so
the pawn on e3 sort of served its
purpose it forced black into this
slightly awkward defensive setup
spending time on rook a6 to b6
uh due to the threats of knight e5 now
that it's served its purpose
magnus is just expanding out with with
e4 all very normal stuff
the challenge now for shock is to finish
development so he does this with
first with bishop e7
it's not so easy to find good squares
for these pieces you can play something
like bishop to b7
but instead shock is trying to clarify
things on the queen side trying to play
this move b4
force this white knight back and get uh
get pressure on the queen side
we start with e5 now for magnus
and we see knight to d5
so
this is the downside to the way that
that shock is played uh magnus now of
course has a tactic
so white to move and seemingly win
material
yeah that's that's exactly right of
course shop didn't hang this uh he's
playing this as a sacrifice
and this is not super uncommon in
uh in catalans when black is able to
keep this extra pawn sometimes you'll
see them
sacrifice the rook like we were talking
about earlier with these queen takes d4
lines when we gave up the rook on a8
uh but he'll sacrifice the rook in order
to keep the extra pawns and use those
pawns as as counter play
in the game however i'm not so sure the
sacrifice was entirely correct here i
think a better line for shock
would have been
well in this case magnus could have
taken on d5 and sort of forced the issue
but instead he chose ab5 trying to get a
better version
uh and here for sure i think this move
knight b4 was uh shock's best idea you
you just don't need to give up this
exchange quite so easily
and knight b4 for the moment would
preserve the material balance
and said shock did take back and now we
get takes on e4 takes on e4 bishop a5
knight c6
and takes uh takes the rook
so at this point you know it's not like
magnus is winning in exchange is is not
a lot
uh and black does have a pawn for it
with very far advanced pawns on the
queen's side but i do think it's it's
white who's pressing here so the
challenge now is to take the small
advantage and turn it into something
bigger
so what do we think white should be
doing in this position
what what are white's goals
and how do we go go about achieving them
well we need to secure our center so
probably on the table yeah so this d4
pawn is a major source of counter play
for for black so we have to keep our eye
on this
um
but yeah what other
ideas sort of come to mind so you
mentioned rick fd1 to defend the pawn
but let's say your pawn is defended what
do you want to do next how are you
improving your position
okay yeah so chipping away at this pawn
majority with b3 definitely makes sense
and overall when you have an extra
exchange um
there are some general principles to
follow which do actually hold true here
you want to open files and invade with
the rooks get to the eighth rank the
seventh rank things like that get get
some activity with your rooks um the
minor pieces tend to do a little bit
better when files are closed down
against the rook which just makes sense
the rooks need the open files to invade
the minor pieces can sort of hop around
like nights and
cut in on the diagonals
um and i'm sorry uh wha what did you
guys
what were you going to say no i like
that i would say the bishop just seemed
so stuck right now
yeah this bishop on g2 and actually
sort of all the white pieces aren't
exactly
um stellar
as it stands right this knight is purely
defensive this bishop is stuck behind
the defensive knight
our rooks seem fine
but they're not exactly active
uh and okay our queen is on a pretty
good position in pretty good position
here um sort of
active on this diagonal and pressuring
the queen side pawns so
the first order of business is
definitely we want to activate all of
our pieces so our pieces are inactive
right now we have a small material plus
but we need to find some way to sort of
bring them to life
so
the first thing we mentioned was this
pawn on d4 is uh weak and right now it's
a attack twice defended once uh but the
question is do you actually have to
defend this uh what happens if it's
let's just say
uh black to move can black actually take
on d4 or does he want to
don't think that he wants to because you
end up with some
tactics down on the e file after the so
if
knight takes on d4 knight knight takes
back and then
um i mean you could play rook uh 81
and then
recapture the pawn
uh and then
yeah exactly yes so ricky won um
uh or you can take on d5 with tempo i
think maybe taking on d5 is a bit better
because
yeah
so you take with tempo this queen has to
move again maybe you take this guy and
what's the result well the result is
i think actually
um i'm not sure if white wins the pawn
or not uh but white definitely rips open
all these open files so this is sort of
disaster for black we know that the
rooks thrive on these open files and by
trading so many pawns now
it's just free reign for the rooks they
can invade you bring these rigs anywhere
and it's going to be very difficult for
if i can draw arrows for black to to
sort of hold the position now
so that's the first thing to notice is
you know just because your opponent has
seemingly made a threat doesn't mean you
necessarily have to respond you know you
you know that the rooks are good on open
files you know that uh getting rid of
this d-pawn uh gives you access to these
weaknesses in the black camp
um
and it might not necessarily be bad for
you so we've decided that maybe we don't
actually care about this d4 pawn so that
gives us a little bit of wiggle room to
improve our pieces so
d84 is safe for the moment um and we're
probably going to be thinking about well
how can black actually make this a
threat and what can we do to improve our
pieces
keeping in mind black is is fighting
back in the center
and to help you out here i want to
mention another general rule that's good
to know
in general not always but in general
it's usually good to get one set of
rooks traded off if you're up the
exchange because two rooks oftentimes
can be redundant especially if there's
only one open file right you know this
rook on f1
um like imagine if the rooks on f1 and
f8 were gone then this would definitely
advantage white because they're still
only the one open file this one rook can
invade and attack all these things and
black has no counter to it no rook
defending
so
potentially getting rid of one set of
rucks could improve your position could
help you activate your other rook
and yeah with that pretty big hint what
move comes to mind i was thinking rook
a8 has one of the options but the reason
i didn't like that is that
he gets to play bishop december with
tempo
against it and then
recapture yeah
recapture with the bishop because of the
what
the hanging ball on h7
oh yeah okay
um yeah so
the problem though is bishop b7 is not a
great move for for black in this
position because
um yes this bishop uh would defend well
but it gives up all of these light
squares over here and this might
actually turn out to be relevant things
like queen f5 might might come in things
like e6 start to be a little bit
tempting sort of attacking over here on
on the king's side
um
and overall we are very very happy about
that trade so let's go ahead and put
this on the board you were saying okay
maybe bishop b7
takes takes uh to keep this guy defended
um i'm sort of wondering if this move
might even just win immediately
something like this could be very very
scary or
i guess if queen f5 this might actually
be a problem but something like knight
g5
uh g6 would have to be played and
yeah i'm sort of uh
sort of improvising here but okay this
this pawn is actually hanging and
i think these complications are are
going to be good for white
although
that's not a guarantee something like
like queen f4 coming in okay h6 is weird
here
but let's say we keep it simple and just
defend our d-pawn first then come in
with queen f5 uh again this is is going
to be favorable for white this rook and
f8 was a nice defensive piece and all of
our pieces are suddenly going to be very
useful once we get this knight in the
game we're attacking on d5 we're
attacking on the king's side and this
bishop again is sort of sorely missed on
this diagonal
so rook a8 is in fact the move turns out
to be a very very strong move
the other reason this is such a good
move is because given a free turn here
uh black likely is trying to play this
move bishop to e6 this turns out to be a
very strong move uh because now all of
these threats against d4 become
reality basically
because
let's say we
tough to find a move here let's say i
play king h2 for some reason
now all of a sudden
we are not getting any of our pawns back
because this bishop is a nice defensive
piece and it also keeps an eye on these
king side king side squares
so rook 8 aimed at making black's best
idea a little bit worse also aimed at
improving the position with this trait
of rooks so
shock comes up with h6 in this position
he
clearly was concerned about these knight
g5 ideas
uh but this turns out to be a pretty big
mistake uh what he should have done is
go for bishop e6 anyways
take back with the bishop and play for
this pressure against d4 white's going
to be a little bit better because rooks
are good pieces to have
and being up in exchanges does actually
mean something
but black definitely has a lot of
counter play you know d4 is weak we have
to defend this guy and then you know
these ideas are going to be in the
position using this extra queen side
pawn
um h6 instead is just a little bit slow
so now again see if you can find
a good repositioning of the white pieces
we want to continue improving the pieces
and getting active
rook fa1 absolutely
and the key point now is that after
bishop e6 which shock does play
uh
what move is available to white that
maybe wasn't so good before
again the idea of bishop b6 is we're
defending this pawn renewing the threat
against d4
um so we can exchange but in this
instance now it might make sense just to
leave the rook on a8 because you know
we're happy to replace it with the rook
on a1 and it's not like this rook is is
going anywhere
the chat says rk6 but this might
actually just be helping black
because it forces the issue after queen
b7 and then we'll have to mover rook
again at the end of the line
b3 to
start opening up the
bishop
b3 is bold but but again this threat is
is real now because we we have
successfully defended on d5 so
uh it's not a shocking move by any means
it's just simple uh what's the best way
to defend the pawn
yes so queen d2 would be okay but i'm a
little bit wary about stepping to these
squares
um and queen d1 does turn out to be just
a very strong move and
it's weird to sort of classify queen d1
as a strong move but compare this
position where the rooks are connected
on the a file we're defending the d-pawn
and still preparing b3 with the option
to recapture with the queen
you can compare this
to if shock had played bishop b6
immediately
let's say takes takes
and now we have to defend our d-pawn
with the rook for example
or we play queen d1 and a rook gets
trapped on f1
without this active rook coming down on
the a file
black is is going to be doing a lot
better than in the main continuation so
this one tempo this one h6 move turns
out to be sort of catastrophic
for for shock because
in this position white's pieces just
aren't quite so harmonious we're very
passive with the rook very passive with
the knight and b3 is going to be a lot
less forceful without
the backup firepower coming in
so again compare that to this position
where now you know our rooks again very
very active and
our pieces are in total harmony our
queen's on a great defensive square uh
preparing b3
and we have a lot of mobility with our
remaining pieces
b4 is the move that that shot comes up
with
uh and now uh magnus does continue with
the big idea of b3
so as stated before black doesn't really
want to open a lot of files which is why
the move c3 makes a lot of sense
uh and now one more super strong idea
for magnus carlsen in this position
um sorry after rook 8 to a6
uh i know i said it's good to to trade
the rooks but in this case both of our
rooks have a pretty good purpose
uh so rook 8 to a6 re uh forces black to
reposition this queen shock chooses
queen c7
and now how do we finish improving the
pieces here with every move magnets just
keeps getting more and more active
so we improved our rooks kind of to the
maximum
our queen is actually not badly placed
on d1 for defensive purposes i was
thinking bishop f1 or
h4 and then kh2 h3 yeah so you're right
to think about these two pieces next
right we talked about this knight being
a little bit passive here and this
bishop being kind of stuck behind the
knight so
bishop f1 was mentioned aiming for these
kinds of squares bishop b5 or something
bishop d3
also h4 king h2 bishop h3 which is
perhaps a little bit slow but would also
activate the bishop
but actually i like this bishop on g2
it's actually well placed here if not
for this knight being in the way and
it's because it's directly targeting
this d5 pawn weakness so i like the
bishop on g2 so how else can we improve
these minor pieces
how else
knight
that's exactly right
91 is is a really nice improving move
and these types of retreating moves
might not stick out to you at first but
it turns out these repositionings here
are really activating white's pieces
and just totally improving uh the
position
so this rook on a6 has done a great job
of preventing this queen from adding
more pressure to d4 and now just as you
said white is planting knight to c2 with
pressure on b4 and potentially even
knight to e3
really
pointing out the sore thumb in black's
position of this d5 pawn
so knight to e1
amazing move
shock of course is not going to go down
without a fight
and he plays this move f6
now the computer doesn't like this move
but i think this is sort of black's last
practical chance you can't really just
sit here and and let white do whatever
he wants
for example after we get this knight to
e3
we are making very serious threats here
and can even start thinking about stuff
like f4 f5 and you know once the pieces
are there we can push the pawns and just
sort of crack black's position like like
a nut
so f6 i think is a very good practical
try you ask white some more questions
and say how are you defending your pawns
in the center
so of course would f4 be a good move
here
probably not because of
the tactic anybody
this one's not so complex
knight takes d4 and that bishop c5 yeah
so knight d4 conveniently defends this
bishop on e6
and f4 of course has horribly weakened
this diagonal and as usual moving the f
pawn not always the best idea
um so that would win a queen which is
why this move is is so testing
um even in general f4 here might not be
the best because we've committed our rx
to the a file even if there weren't a
tactic and this would help activate
black stroke so f6 just a great move
overall no matter what ben feingold says
always play f6
um
so the question now is how are we
responding to this move by black
it's sort of his last practical try
posing all these problems to white but
it feels as though as normal f6 is not a
good move maybe ben feingold does know
what he's talking about so how do we
punish black for weakening his position
like this
how can we prove that even though
this is a good practical try
weakening all these squares is still a
bad thing
yeah queen h5 um the problem is your
queen's a little bit lonely um
it's going to be tough to checkmate
black here and
it is still relevant to uh to be losing
uh these pawns in the center
and there are actually a few good moves
here queen h5 might be totally fine
but i really like what magnus chose in
this instance
and yeah somebody in the chat actually
has a great idea so f6 weakens these
light squares
so how can we target these light squares
well maybe we will adjust our plan from
knight c2 to e3 instead go for knight d3
to f4 when pressure on uh d5 is still
there this bishop is now attacked and we
are eyeing basically every square that
f6 is weakened so knight d3 is a
fantastic move now of course you have to
back this up with calculation
which magnus carlsen of course was was
very capable of doing so the danger here
is that you might be hanging your d-pawn
or your e-pawn so black tries to take
but magnus has this under control
how are we going to respond to d takes
e5
um first though let me just point out
this move not going to be great for i
think a number of reasons
um
i think this might win a piece rook e6
is also quite strong
with you know this this still coming
through and winning
uh winning some material but i think
knight f4 first might be even stronger
the knight's attacked the bishop is
attacked twice tough to defend
everything and white's going to be doing
well
so fe 5 instead
and how to reply
yeah so you said knight takes e5 which
is i agree better than pawn takes e5
because i think pawn takes e5 uh doesn't
really make a threat and we sort of need
to do things uh
a little bit more immediately here so
knight e5 is great because it threatens
this knight on c6 and sort of keeps the
tactics flowing it's the force the more
forcing move
black of course is almost obliged to
take
you can't really defend this knight or
something because this guy is loose
so knight takes e5
and now which piece do we capture
of course we take the bishop rather than
the knights don't want to allow the
black queen to sort of invade like this
although
here you just take on e6 and then you
have the tactic on
d5
you make a good point um this might also
be winning
d takes e5 probably also good i i guess
instead of that
black would have to to grovel somehow
but even groveling is tough here
something like this maybe maybe the game
continues but black is is probably going
to be doing well you do have to look out
for the c2 idea though
but okay rookie 6 is great d takes e5
probably also winning because black is
sort of falling apart by this point but
c2
still introduces some tricks
so of course we're just going to
do what in this position
a lot of people would say move the queen
turns out moving the queen is totally
winning
um
but okay no you do have to move the
queen
wait a second hold on i'm forgetting
what happened
okay you do have to move the queen once
but then black attacks her queen again
and now of course
we're done moving our queen we're done
getting pushed around
and magnus comes up with what move
rick takes e7
yes so bishop d5 is the movie played
rookie seven i suspect is probably also
winning i think everything is winning so
it's a little bit slow to ask you for
moves
yeah this one looks good yeah take take
is is still going to be plenty but
bishop d5 was his choice with just
discover check threats
and i believe here um
sorry knight d3 wasn't even played um
after queen e1 shock it had enough and
resigned but knight d3 i thought it
would be fun to point out bishop d5 with
rookie 7 coming and just
just all the nastiness so
this game is pretty typical uh of what
magnus has been doing for this entire
tournament he comes up with some tiny
tiny opening idea to get to some
position the opponent has to uh to play
on their own
and then
i just plays all the best moves and his
opponent doesn't
uh
but there were some really really great
ideas to to point out here
number one understanding your goal uh
right out of the opening in the catalan
we're trying to activate on this
diagonal we're trying to recapture this
pawn and when you have such a firm idea
of what you should be trying to do you
know trying to take on c4 trying to
attack on this diagonal that's so you
can come up with weird looking moves
like e3 you know when you when you're
very very confident and what the
principle you're going for is that's
when you play something like e3 because
you know this move helps you it helps
you play knight e5 which is a very
desirable move it helps you play queen
c2 to attack here and it improves your
position um after that
white's moves come very naturally every
move is
uh played with the idea of further
weakening the light squares uh and uh
attacking to to regain the pawn queen c2
a4 very very direct knight c3 also very
direct
and then here
magnus comes up with this nice e4 e5
plan to shake loose black's defensive
setup
we have this nice tactic
to win material
and then we just uh we see magnus
activate with uh you know computer-like
precis precision here uh you've won some
material the next step just improve your
pieces with every single move rook a8
activates the rook rook a1 continues
activating queen d1 the defensive setup
we need to play b3
and then
rook a6 to allow knight e1 and this
final repositioning
uh is is what gives magnus the win and
so magnus turned this tiny plus of being
up the exchange for the this queen side
pawn mass uh by just playing very
accurate moves that improve his pieces
turn that into a winning advantage in a
matter of six or seven moves after this
91 black is pretty close to busted and
then black
throws in the towel with one more
practical try but magnus is not going to
mess this up finds all the correct moves
and is able to uh to win the game
so questions on this game questions on
this game because it's kind of a dense
game
but magnus kind of makes it look easy he
improves the pieces takes the material
solves the tactics and the game is over
but any questions
all right well let's move on to the next
horror story in the catalan uh and the
victim this time is going to be aneesh
giri so anish i believe is also having a
good tournament losing only to magnus in
this game
um
but this game i have to admit was was
sort of ugly so
once again magnus is staying true he's
been playing the catalan in every um
uh every game basically with the white
pieces bishop g2 castles and castles so
compared to the last game we saw black
first play this move bishop e7 and
castle before he considered taking on c4
we saw shock take on c4 first
so slightly different line but now anish
does go ahead and capture this pawn on
c4 and again white's ideas are going to
be centered around recapturing this pawn
um there are two
super main ideas here queen c2 and 95
are the very normal ways of playing both
with the idea of taking this guy
queen a4 is basically a worse version of
queen to c2 because it allows a 6b5
um
and then b behind the these moves moves
like knight bd2 knight c3 and knight a3
are sidelines
in this case magnus uses knight a3 very
much a sideline
um but it's very direct you know you
attack the pawn on c4 you stop b5 and
you say i'm going to take this pawn next
turn
to prevent this black parts with this
dark squared bishop in order to fracture
white's pawns further
and then place bishop to d7 so
in the catalan as black there are a few
different ways you can play
but the same central idea tends to be at
the heart either you are fully
committing to trying to keep this pawn
on c4 as we saw a shock do you try to
keep this pawn alive you play for
counter play using this pawn
or you go for something like what anish
is doing here which is you try to get
your own bishop
on this light square diagonal
effectively neutralizing white's big
advantage right white's advantage stems
from all the pressure this bishop gives
him on this diagonal if you're able to
neutralize that with bishop c6 or with
bishop b7 somehow then black is
oftentimes doing totally fine so we see
anish going for the more you know i
would say conservative plan of freely
parting with with the extra material
he's been given in order to just
solidify his position
and
uh neutralize white's bishop
uh magnus in this case comes up with
another unique idea of playing a4 um
the lead chess database says this has
been played before by like a 2300
but who's looking at those games i'm
calling this a novelty so of course what
is magnus's idea behind
pawn to a4 here
makes it significantly harder to defend
the c pawn he uh opens up a3 for his
dark square bishop yeah
so those two things i think are enough
it gives a little bit of space on the
queen's side this might actually be a
little bit of a negative because this
pawn is a bit of a target here on a4
uh but more importantly after the simple
bishop c6 again a very natural move it
does grant this bishop this nice a3 f8
diagonal which is an idea that shows up
in some other openings but in this
position uh it's it's virtually never
been seen
so bishop a3 and this is the the point
for for magnus is he's activating the
bishop here rather than somewhere along
this diagonal
again we see magnus's sort of
ideas
in the catalan are
centering around this dark squared
bishop again this bishop is sometimes a
problem piece for for white it's hard to
find a good spot for it it's not super
comfortable on f4 because these pawns on
f2 and g3 sort of
limit its retreating squares it can be
vulnerable uh same on g5 it's often time
just pushed back by h6 uh so magnus
finding unique ways to make use of this
bishop
we see rook to e8 by black and then
magnus just plays queen to c2 again very
simple aiming to recapture this pawn
uh anish again
playing a little bit more a little bit
differently than shock rather than fully
committing to stuff like b5 a5 c6
anisha's very very happy to to part with
this pawn essentially whenever
so much so that magnus doesn't feel it's
necessary to recapture right away just
plays rook a to c1 further activating
now a6 by black is perhaps hinting that
hey if if you don't take this pawn soon
you might lose your chance
and so magnus captures
we see knight b6 by anish queen to c3
and as said before moving this pawn to
a4 does have a drawback drawback is that
it's a bit of a target and we see anish
successfully capturing on a4
going up a pawn once again
and now we get queen to b3 by magnus
and queen to d5 by anish geary so
so far so good um black has successfully
planted this bishop on c6 uh
opposing white's strongest minor piece
on g2 uh black also has won a pawn on a4
in return
uh white has some nice looking open
files but
if nothing happens soon at the end of
the day black is up a pawn this bishop
is opposed and i would actually prefer
to be black here if if something drastic
doesn't happen soon so
see if you can find magnus's uh super
exciting idea to bring his position back
to life
falling out um just by annihilating the
next place
rook takes c6 is exactly right and uh
how do you come up with moves like rip
to c6 where it takes c6 well it's all
about you know understanding the
character of your opening um that's sort
of the common theme here magnus just has
such a good grip
on the ideas in the catalan what it is
white is playing for
that's uh these moves like rick to c6
become very very natural very playable
um
and beyond that how does that apply to
you guys well
so many people i've seen now are
obsessed with like learning all this
theory and like stupid gambits but
that's not what what chess really looks
like if you don't need necessarily all
the theory memorized if you understand
the ideas behind your opening understand
hey i'm playing the catalan if this
bishop uh isn't active then i'm doing
something wrong uh then moves like rick
takes c6 are very findable so
uh awesome sacrifice by magnus re uh
reinvigorates his position
and with the simple sacrifice of this
piece now the moves again are gonna
start flowing very naturally so how do
we follow up this sacrifice
exactly knight to e5 this same exact
idea that we've seen before actually
attacks this queen twice
anish has to move it so he comes to b5
now do we want to uh trade these queens
so i've gotta
pull up the chat again
you said you don't think so
um so yeah definitely not right we just
sacrificed some material we don't really
want to simplify things uh plus our
queen adds some nice pressure to this
knight on a4 so simply queen to c2
um not falling for uh you know the trick
of getting a little bit of material back
which is just not going to be enough
here for example bishop b7 i think would
be a mistake
uh
something
actually let me
let me calculate a little bit these
positions always end up being trickier
than i anticipate i think something like
rook to b8 is good
and after
after bishop c6 for example
what is happening here
i don't know i give up what's happening
here yeah queen b3 is good and then
knight c3 okay and you might be getting
this back uh
but you know what's the point of getting
your exchange back if black has
successfully activated all the pieces
and is uh in fact about to go up
material it looks like
okay so not falling for the trap of
getting the material back right away we
sacrifice the rook for activity so
magnus continues playing for activity
with queen to c2
uh knight to d5 is a niche gary's
response but this turns out to be
essentially the the losing move or
or the the first big mistake in the game
um knight d5 of course very human move
you want to block this bishop out uh
this is what white is playing for
but it turns out that tactically this
this move is just not going to be enough
um okay rook b1 is a great start and
that's what magnus plays
but after queen to a5
what is our our knockout punch here
because if you're not careful
something like knight to c3 is
potentially going to ruin your day
you've got some threats against this
bishop on a3 got some threats against
knight e2
with knight e2
threats against the a pun potentially
uh so black definitely is is fighting
back here
but white to move
and
black
a very tough time
uh knight to c4 is not going to get the
job done i think we have queen to c3
the knight is hanging i agree all right
what's going on knight c4 queen c3 i
think has to be the idea um queen a4
okay i don't get it knight c4 what's
what's the trick what's the trick
who's going to find it
no we can do this one this i i looked at
this before the lecture and i'm
almost certain it's queen c3
so queen c3 coin a4 what's going on
uh b5 of course yeah b5
um
and then i think uh black black should
be doing well all right let's let's
check just to make sure
oh i'm don't look at that okay yeah
queen c3 very good queen a4 b5 and this
is uh
this is not so fun anymore for
um
for for white you can't go rook c1
because knight e2 were b2 just rook b8
and yeah bla black is crushing it now we
got the queens off the board up in
exchange easy peasy
so knight c4 not good enough not quite
that easy to beat anish geary
and the chat has actually found the best
move that magnus missed in the game
which is of course bishop to e4
sort of a
weird looking idea
but there are some very unusual mating
patterns in the position so let's say
you know you get greedy try something
like knight to c3 as we were talking
about
of course what happens here
i believe in you guys to find a mate in
two
oh
yeah it's that easy it's a really
unusual pattern having this bishop on a3
helping to attack the king but in this
instance it's it's very very strong king
h8 knight f7
and that king has nowhere to go
absolutely nowhere to go so bishop e4
actually gives a niche gear some very
serious problems that that are not going
to be solvable
um it turns out that g6 does you know
keep the position alive for the moment
but this move turns out to be sort of
horribly horribly weakening um
so
uh
bishop b4 really great inclusion
um but the idea at hearts is to take on
d5 pointing out the fact that this queen
is a little bit overworked and after
this knight disappears that is going to
open the floodgates for for white to
start invading
um but
after bishop to d5 anishigiri misses his
chance to sort of let himself back into
the game so the the really clever
tactical idea to stay in the game here
for a niche i believe is this nice move
knight to c3
um the move we've been talking about but
even after uh white has captured one of
our pieces it does turn out to be
potentially saving the game what's the
point the point is that after bishop to
b4
attacking two things at the same time
we're gonna sacrifice this knight
and take back on d5 so we've actually
lost a piece here with black but
remember we're up in exchange to start
with so sacrificing a piece back not
going to be the worst idea and it helps
us solidify the position so so much
now
why is bishop e4 so much better
well if you compare this exact same line
bishop d5 knight c3 bishop b4 take take
take all of a sudden uh white can just
play knight g4 here and this is uh you
know this is horrible this is just
crushing all of a sudden the pawn on g7
very very important for black to to hold
everything together
for example king g7 bishop d2 and you're
already looking at
looking at some devastation for the
black pieces here potentially okay rook
c1 first to defend this guy
um and then you know rook ac8 smaller
rook c5 as well
it's just it's it's a horrible horrible
mess here and uh just to show you a fun
line h5 for example
you know already stuff like this is is
in the air and it's just
just devastation just devastation for
the black king
knight of six is coming queen g7 is
coming
queen h5 is coming
and you're just you're getting
annihilated getting annihilated
so that one little difference the pawn
on g7 versus g6 uh makes actually a big
difference in the game if anish would
have been able to find knight c3
unfortunately for him he does not and
after the move uh he takes d5 white's
task is very much simplified and he just
continues now taking on b7
and uh white has or black has way too
many weaknesses in particular f7
and once again this bishop is proving
its usefulness here preventing black
from comfortably defending this
c5 was the niche's attempt but just
queen f5 does
pose some serious problems rook to f8
and magnus simply just captures this guy
with you know some some pretty serious
threats
queen to d8 was a niche's try but simply
takes on c5 is good enough queen f6 is
simplifying the niche has avoided
checkmate of course that's not going to
save the game the c pawn is a little bit
too strong here we get c7
and
knight to d6 this allows magnus to win
back the exchange right away
and
at the end of the day uh we get to this
end game
white has two more pawns this pawn is
likely going to fall as well and
giri had had enough in this position and
simply resigned just to show you a
couple more moves
black is not actually in time to take
this guy because this is a fork
say knight g7 takes
magnus is clearly going to win uh in
short order here
so
another really impressive game by by
magnus carlson and again it just goes to
show his deep understanding of these
catalan positions i think he had done a
lot of work prepping these things for
the recent world championship match
and now the it's it's paying dividends
all that hard work on the catalan
so any questions on this game before i
do a quick review and then actually hand
it off to uh our grand master in
residence josh fadell but any questions
okay well let's take one more look then
at what happened in this game
we started with the normal catalan ideas
we saw magnus not adopt one of the main
lines go for knight a3 instead after we
see black take off the knights to
preserve the the c pawn a little bit
longer
geary chooses bishop d7 again the idea
is to neutralize this bishop on g2
without getting too attached to the pawn
on c4
magnus comes up with this novel idea of
activating the bishop on the a3 to f8
diagonal
which he does so immediately then we see
him go after the c pawn
and black continues activating
and then a6 forcing the issue otherwise
b5 would come
knight to b6 magnus sacrifices this pawn
on a4
and after queen to d5
the key sacrifice here understanding
that white can actually be worse if you
give up this pawn and don't get this
activity of course we need to sacrifice
this rook on c6
and activate with knight to e5 keep the
queens on keep the pressure up and then
anish actually just immediately makes
this knight to d5 mistake which allows
magnus to take over the game with bishop
e4 which would be winning immediately or
as we saw in the game well bishop b1
first and then bishop e4
which would be winning or as we saw in
the game bishop takes d5
which geary did not respond to correctly
allowing all this activity to uh just
sort of take over just like that the
queen side collapses the king's side
collapses and and the game is over in
magnus carlson's favor
so uh really impressive games magnus
actually has won a third game in the
catalan against richard rapport this
tournament and he was also i think plus
one and a half out of the opening
against jordan vin forrest uh which
wasn't quite a pure catalan uh but that
was uh jordan's doing he played i think
a grunfeld setup which doesn't really
allow for for the uh the true catalan
uh and so he's been winning in all of
his games in the catalan he won three
out of four drew the last one um but had
a winning position at multiple points so
this guy is like uh pretty good at chess
magnus carlson that's my prediction now
is it good enough to get to 2900 again
i'm not so sure he's plus four in this
tournament and that's only good enough
to win like two and a half rating points
so it's gonna be a long journey for him
for sure but at the end of the day it's
clear that magnus carlsen knows
something about chess that the rest of
us don't and uh he continues to prove it
um okay so thank you all so much for
joining me here tonight uh as i
mentioned josh fidel will be coming in
to teach right after me here it's gonna
be fun super glad to have josh back in
town it's been a while uh hopefully
y'all can stick around for that
and as always my name is caleb dendy
thank you so much for watching and i
will see you guys next time
[Music]
you